a running gag pulled from real life a
season delayed by a rehab stint and the
biggest prima donna on four legs here's
how Frazier beat the odds to become one
of TV's biggest successes officially the
Frasier Crane character was the creation
of Cheers executive producers Glenn and
Les Charles but writers David Angel
Peter Casey and David Lee who later
created the spin-off played a vital role
in shaping the character from his
infancy Angel joined cheers during the
first season in 1983 when Casey and Lee
were still under contract at The
Jeffersons a monologue from their first
tear script written before the character
had a name or an actor was used for
auditions Kelsey Grammar told GQ about
his audition for the role when I
auditioned for the 20 people that were
in the room I didn't get a single laugh
I thought holy I'm done I blew this
completely I put the script down thanked
everybody and said I'm going to go and
see if I can get some laughs out on the
street but then they sent me a bottle of
champagne and said welcome to Cheers
grammar would end up playing Dr Frazier
crane for the next two decades Casey and
Lee received an Emmy nomination for
their cheers debut they joined the cheer
staff full-time after they completed
their obligation to The Jeffersons
eventually Angel Casey and Lee left
cheers to create the sitcom Wings and
while that series enjoyed an eighth
season run Dr Frazier crane would soon
call upon them again the second season
of Cheers ended with the breakup of Sam
Malone played by Ted Danson and Diane
Chambers played by Shelley Long in the
third season opener the rebound Diane
returned to the bar with a new boyfriend
psychiatrist Dr Frazier crane hello Sam
I'm Dr Fraser crane I'm sorry I startled
you Frazier was introduced as an
obstacle between Sam and Diane he was
the kind of polished intellectual that
Diane always claimed to desire Frazier
was also the opposite of the coarse
blue-collar wisecracking Sam while
Frasier was pretentious overall he was a
pretty good guy but his character served
the plot as an antagonist a wedge
between the two main romantic leads
Kelsey Grammer received mountains of
hate mail and occasional in-person
harassment for keeping Sam and Diane
apart I hate Frasier Crane Frazier and
Diane became engaged and jetted off to
Italy to get married but Diane rejected
Frazier at the altar taking him out of
the Sam and Diane equation as he
struggled to pick up the pieces of his
life Frazier stuck around at the bar and
took on an identity of his own he
ultimately became one of the most
popular Cheers characters earning
grammar two Emmy nominations for Best
Supporting Actor in a comedy series when
the massively popular cheers came to a
close in 1993 NBC and Paramount
Television wanted a new sitcom to retain
the audience a new series starring a
popular member of the Cheers cast seemed
like just the ticket but Kelsey Grammer
resisted the idea he wanted a completely
new series character and premise grammar
had already approached former cheers
writers David Angel Peter Casey and
David Lee about developing such a series
they pitched an original and bizarre
sitcom In which grammar played a
disabled media Tycoon who ran his Empire
from his bedroom Paramount executive
John Pike rejected this concept and
convinced the team to develop a Frasier
spin-off grammar agreed on the condition
that the series would not be a family
comedy featuring Frasier with his wife
and son from cheers this was easy to
accommodate since cheers had already put
Frazier in a precarious place with his
contentious spouse Dr Lilith sternin
played by BB new Earth my God woman I
drive a stake through your heart but I
don't think anything could kill you
foreign
young Frederick played by Trevor Einhorn
would occasionally appear but those
relationships wouldn't be the center of
the show one of the ways the Frasier
co-creators distanced the spin-off from
cheers was to place a literal distance
between Frasier and the cheers Boston
location this would also lessen Studio
or network demands to have the Cheers
characters visit Frasier the series was
going to be set in Denver Colorado but
after the state passed some harshly
anti-gay legislation The Producers
changed it to Seattle Washington Seattle
was a city largely unexplored as a
setting on television and was a growing
center of culture that offered story
opportunities for the cultured
psychiatrist instead of using exterior
establishing shots and theme music
between scenes Frasier divided sequences
with clever white on black title cards
over silence sequences on Frasier could
run as long as they were funny despite
trends of fast gags and Quick Cuts for
so-called short attention spans some
scenes spend an entire act despite
transcend research to the contrary the
pacing was extremely successful the idea
of Dr Frazier crane hosting a talk radio
show was almost a Cheers episode but it
became the core premise for the Frasier
spin-off to gain insight into the radio
workplace the writers visited kabc's Dr
David viscos show in Los Angeles the
heart of the series was inspired by the
fathers of co-creators Peter Casey and
David Lee Casey's father had been a San
Francisco police officer while Lee's
father suffered a stroke which brought
in the issue of a child becoming the
caretaker to a parent since Frazier
would be working at a radio station he
would need a hand taking care of his
father Martin crane played by John
Mahoney so Jane leaves was cast as a
full-time health care worker Fraser
crane was going to be an only child
until casting assistant Shirley Guthrie
suggested David Hyde Pierce to play
Fraser's younger brother the creators
were interested in the idea of having a
younger foil for Frasier essentially
serving as the person he would have
become if he'd never come to cheers and
so Dr Niles crane was created for Pierce
Frazier you're my brother that entitles
you to my bone marrow and one of my kids
but this is an imposition NBC happily
pre-approved John Mahoney David Hyde
Pierce and Jane leaves before they were
even certain the actors were available
the most difficult role to cast turned
out to be Frasier's radio producer Roz
Doyle The Producers requested a wide
variety of actors to audition to see
what each brought to it Lisa Kudrow won
the role after years of guest spots on
other early 90s sitcoms including cheers
they loved her quirky Persona and began
to shape the character around her but
during the first week of rehearsals they
found that this Roz was losing her edge
and could no longer go toe-to-toe with
Frasier Perry Gilpin another favorite
from the audition was then offered the
role Dr crane on line two we have Stuart
who's having a problem with delayed
gratification well he's just gonna have
to wait
Gulpin told Vanity Fair that there were
no hurt feelings between the two actors
and things worked out fine for Kudrow
who found great success as Phoebe on
Friends Frasier star Kelsey Grammer is
known to be a reliable level
professional on the studio set however
his personal story is fraught with
tragic and unsettling incidents the
grandfather who had raised him was lost
to cancer when grammar was 25. his
father and younger sister were victims
of two separate grisly murders he lost
his two half-brothers in a scuba diving
accident grammar himself had a
decades-long struggle with alcohol and
cocaine during production of Frasier's
fourth season in 1996 grammar was in a
single car accident while driving under
the influence of alcohol his Frasier
friends held an intervention and he
entered rehab at the Betty Ford Center
where he stayed for a month it may be an
unwise matter doesn't learn from his own
mistakes but it's an absolute idiot that
doesn't learn from other people's
in 2016 grammar announced himself as a
reformed alcoholic who drinks regularly
in moderation but he says he's given up
cocaine for good the cast of Frasier got
along exceptionally well with relatively
little conflict between the actors even
during Kelsey grammer's personal
struggles his professional and personal
relationships among the cast are
described as mostly stable and amicable
the real Primadonna in the cast was the
dog moose was the real name of the Jack
Russell Terrier who played Martin's
beloved pet Eddie while the on-screen
Eddie seemed sweet and benign off-screen
moose was described in a 1994 Washington
Post article as unfriendly and
business-like in the DVD featurette
behind the couch John Mahoney seconded
that description adding that moose
eagerly cooperated with his trainer
Matilda Cagney but had no interest in
the rest of the cast moose also used to
bite Mahoney according to Kelsey Grammer
who tended to be the one with a harsh
just words about his canine co-star
eventually moose began to split the role
with his son Enzo but Moose and denzo
didn't get along very well either Siri's
co-creator Peter Casey told Vanity Fair
apparently it was one of those Classic
parent-child Hollywood rivalries one
source of the series humor is the
portrayal of Frasier and his brother
Niles as having more in common with the
stereotypes of a gay man than a straight
one and by two Balinese loots two
decoupage kits two pairs of lederhosen
guest characters would often misread
their sexuality resulting in escalating
misunderstandings one reason why this
line of humor worked was the influence
of gay Talent behind the scenes
including co-creator David Lee and
writer Joe Keenan Keenan penned 24
episodes including the Matchmaker a
farce of sexual miscues which won an
Emmy a wga award a DGA award and a glad
media award David Hyde Pierce is coming
out and marriage to his longtime partner
Brian Hargrove in 2008 is now common
knowledge Dan Butler who played the
hyper masculine sportscaster Bob Bulldog
Briscoe was already out during the run
of the show there's nothing I can do to
appeal to your sense of decency hey I
have no sense of decency that way my
other senses are enhanced
series co-creator David Lee believes the
joke isn't that Frasier or Niles are
secretly gay as he feels some viewers
have misinterpreted it instead the joke
is that they're straight but extremely
against type Siri's writer producer Joe
Keenan told the advocate they were
metrosexuals a good five or six years
before the term was coined Frazier came
to an end on its own terms after 11
seasons in 2004. when other 90s sitcoms
like Will and Grace and Murphy Brown
returned to television and streaming
services during the reboot happy 2010s
Rumblings of a Frasier Revival weren't
far behind it became a real possibility
in 2018 when Kelsey Grammer began to
float the idea publicly and take
meetings with Paramount Executives if
anyone understands the value of
restraint and taking things slowly it is
yours truly in 2021 Viacom green lit a
new Fraser series starring Kelsey
Grammer on their Paramount plus
streaming service other original cast
members have not confirmed their
involvement although both Perry Gilpin
and Bibi new Earth seem enthusiastic
about the idea of reprising their roles
Jane Lee waves might participate if it
doesn't conflict with her current role
on the fox drama the resident David Hyde
Pierce however had expressed disinterest
in returning according to a 2017 vulture
interview How I Met Your Mother writer
producer Chris Harris and life in pieces
writer Joe cristali were announced as
showrunners but there's no word of
involvement or endorsement we've heard
from surviving original series creators
Peter Casey and David Lee when Paramount
plus officially greenlit a Fraser sequel
series Kelsey Grammer confirmed that the
original cast would not return initially
he envisioned a reunion but without
David Hyde Pierce's interest grammar and
the team decided to rethink the premise
we all know we weren't going to stay
together forever I mean that's not what
life is about grammar calls it Frazier's
third act with new characters in a
different setting the absence of the
original series characters including the
off-screen loss of Frasier's father
Martin will be addressed in the new
series just as Frazier bought a single
ticket from Boston to Seattle when he
left cheers Frazier will again find a
new home to reunite with family members
and friends in in the new series
Frasier's son Freddy is now a young man
who would rather be a firefighter than a
scholar played by British actor Jack
fetmore Scott of the ABC series
deception Freddie attempts to resolve
his differences with his father much as
Frasier tried with Martin in the
original Niles and Daphne's son David
who was born during the original series
finale is now an awkward College
freshman played by Anders Keith Jess
salguero of the series why the last man
will portray Freddie's outgoing roommate
Eve in addition to the younger cast
veteran actor Nicholas Lindhurst star of
the BBC sitcom good night sweetheart
will portray Frazier's Harvard College
Buddy Alan Cornwall and talks alexandore
of ABC's the neighbors and Castle is set
to play Alan's colleague Olivia whether
it's Madness or sanity to expect the new
Frasier to equal the original fans will
be getting more appointments with the
sophisticated shrink on top of his first
22 years on television
foreign